your birthday star is the star in our  galaxy that is as many light years away  from Earth as you are years old it takes  light a year to travel one light year so  when you look at your birthday star you  are seeing that star as it appeared the  day you were born light from your  birthday star that reaches your eye came  out of its Sun just as you were coming  out of your mother your birthday star is  always changing it's a different star  that's further and further from Earth as  you get older luckily there's a website  that will help you find your current  birthday star just put in your birth  date today my best match is 10 days off  but in three months light from mufrid  will reach Earth that has been traveling  towards us for just as long as I've been  here waiting I can't wait to meet my  Starlight twins we have been traveling  through space alone our entire lives but  soon we will meet